Anxiety disorders affect nearly 20
percent of adults in North America. That's about 40
million people.
When we're feeling anxious or stressed, sometimes
it feels good to go home and indulge in some well deserved
vices. We've all planted our butts in our couches
and binge watched our favorite shows while eating pizza.
But as tempting as that sounds, is it really
the best thing for us? And as it turns out,
some of our guilty pleasures may be agitating our
anxiety instead of reducing it. Here are 8
everyday habits that may be stressing you out more than you know.
Number 1: Being a Couch Potato
When you spend all day huddled up in bed or on your sofa,
you give up the chance to decrease your tension,
improve your sleep, and stabilize your mood.
Yes, your daily activeness has a direct affect on your mood.
Regular exercise is important in maintaining your
mental health because it reduces stress. Just 10 minutes
of exercise a day can improve your alertness and concentration.
Number 2: Do you skip meals
because you're too busy being out and about? You're only causing
your body stress. When you don't
have enough to eat, your blood sugar levels take a dive;
making you feel anxious, sluggish, and irritated.
Want to feel calm and happy? Eat foods like
berries, spinach, and fish.
All these foods and their nutrients work towards the elevation
of mood and the warding off of depression.
Number 4: Coffee Addiction
Caffeine is no friend to anyone who is prone to anxiety.
Caffeine stimulates our fight or flight response centers
mimicking our physiological reactions to dangerous
or scary situations. This makes us feel alert
and energized. But this simulation
also means that we have to deal with fight or flight symptoms.
Increased heart rate, sweaty palms,
an upset stomach, and shaky hands.
A good alternative that can wake us up in the morning is a cold glass of water
with lemon or cucumber. Or both if you're feeling
festive.
Number 5: Scrolling Through Social Media
It's a common habit to scroll through your Instagram
or Facebook in our free time. But being on social media
can take time away from other more important
things. Like being present at work or getting tasks done.
The realization that you've spent 20 minutes looking at your Instagram feed
can lead to regret and anxiety
for not using your time more productively.
Being able to look at the best parts of other people's lives online
can often make us feel jealous and upset about our own lives.
Unplug for a while. Focus on people
in front of you and spend time with friends and loved ones.
Those are the interactions that help you feel happy.
Number 6: You Don't Get Sleep.
You need at least 7 hours of sleep in order to
feel healthy and energized in the day.
Anything less, and you'll feel the effects of sleep deprivation.
These effects include heightened stress, mood destabilization,
poor cognitive functioning, and lowered immune system.
Sleep deprivation can also cause anticipatory
anxiety, which is the anxiety you feel right before
events like heading into work, having to speak publicly,
or taking a test.
Are you a habitual pre-sleep computer or phone user?
These over-stimulating gadgets are preventing your brain from
winding down. Try reading a book before bed, or
better yet, pre-sleep breathing meditation.
Number 7: Spending Too Much Time Alone
This might not seem
productive for someone who suffers from anxiety, but spending time
with other people can help to alleviate symptoms of anxiety.
Spending time with supportive friends
and developing healthy, positive attachments can help to
improve social functioning and increase happiness.
Alone time is important every once in a while,
especially for all you introverts out there, but it's
just as important to get out there and to see your friends.
Number 8: Listening to Moody Music
Yes, sad songs can affect your mood.
The emotion and affect of the songs you listen to have direct
effects on your current emotions.
If you're already feeling anxious or sad,
it's probably not in your best interest to play your breakup playlist (idk)
That sad tune will exacerbate the sadness
and anxiety you may already be feeling.
The next time you're feeling sad or anxious, listen to something happy.
Make a playlist full of calming or positive music that will
help you find your happy place.
Now remember, these habits are not surefire anxiety
triggers for everyone.
Doing any of these things will not guarantee a bout of anxiety,
but they will increase your chances
What do you think?
Any anxiety inducing habits you've been guilty of?
Are there any habits you know of that should have made it on the list?
Let us at Psych2Go know in the comments section down below.
Wanna read more about the topic? Visit psych2go.net
using the link down below to view the original article.
And don't forget to subscribe for updates on new videos.